all right tanya
tanya where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from los angeles
california
and tell me about it and i'm really i
grew up in south central
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young no
my dad raised us because he told us that
my mother was
uh unfit mother and that she wasn't uh
up the park to take care of us
so your mom wasn't in your life no no
partially
partially i would have to run away from
home and go see my mom
and uh she stayed down here downtown
is that right yeah and my dad used to he
used to jump on my mother a lot
you know and uh because my mother
had turned um to liking women so
he wouldn't allow her to see us
and how would you describe your
childhood well
yeah um what kind of stuff went on
i i i gotta like not just a woman i got
maybe like a beating every day
you know my dad he took a lot of his uh
anger out of me that he had from my mom
because i looked like her um
i guess that was his way of showing me
you know on
his affection or how he feel you know
which
when i got older i did ask him why did
he do me like that
i got it with me i left home at 12 years
old you know i came home one day and
uh my sister was on the porch crying
and i asked her why because he had a lot
of women you know different women every
other knowledge what did your dad do for
money
he's so dope so crack cocaine
and uh
it's it's it's it's a lot of physical
abuse
yeah without any sexual abuse no no
no not at all not no he never he never
did nothing like that to me
but one of my sisters that i'm aware of
you know
but um i really thought that my dad
didn't love me you know he scarred me
because he used to tell me that
uh he found me in an oily blanket in the
alley and all this
you know he should say things like you
know just to hurt my feelings or
whatever you know
call me names like bubble eyed fish eye
fools and
stuff like that you know and i gotta i
got like a whooping every day if i
didn't do it my sister's blame is on me
and by that time i figured well okay
well i did do it you know it
had me believing i did you know um
once i got out of grade school and went
to junior high
that's when all my problems started
because i didn't feel like i
was you know worthy enough you know to
keep on going with that
you know to fit in with those and then
think i could do the work or whatever
because like but i didn't give it a
chance
you know i used to ditch school you know
because i you know people used to tease
me a lot so
i had very low self-esteem very long
and what did you do how far did you go
in school two to twelfth grade
and after school you went where out the
streets i was already in the streets
you were working as a prostitute yeah i
did that i did that you know
um what age did you start working
streets my dad put me in a girls home
called garden gates
and um i went home one day i was
supposed to go on a home pass and i
never went back home
you know um i started working the
streets and stuff like that
to support my habit i got into drugs got
started on
cracks and uh
wow
[Music]
i had a lot of bad experiences you know
it's it's
it's uh what kind of stuff do you go
through
raped more than once you know um
because i was doing anything for crack
at the time because i didn't know no
better
you know you know until i learned
from my experiences of living it you
know that
it's not all about that because i'm
worth more than that you know
um but um
as the years went by i just i started
learning from the lifestyle for
being a street life i basically raised
myself
so i never went back home and you were
working with a pimp or on your own
i had a pimp in the beginning i ran into
one and
he was teaching me how to steal how to
tricks cars
and you know like uh where to search and
you know like if they get out to go get
the room start searching
or whatever how to you know all kind of
stuff you know i went to prison twice
um
by me robbing somebody going by wheel
from the stuff that i hear he had taught
me
what to do you know i went to jail they
gave me five years
my second term was 10. i did 9 years 9
months and 28 days
this is for what robbery robert 2 11
would uh attempt to do bodily harm and
kidnap
and that was in connection with the
prostitution work yes so our only
connection with that yeah so very very
often the prostitute
is actually her motivation is robbery
that was my you know that was my thing
but uh which i've turned my life around
on that you know i learned you know okay
well you can't do that you don't know
what i'm getting caught up you know just
because i won't get caught up somebody
might come back on me i might run into
the same person again
is it a common thing that a prostitute
is using sex as a way to distract the
man so you can actually steal
absolutely absolutely a lot of men don't
understand that
absolutely i think it's sex for money
but it's actually sex for distraction
and
clearing robberies absolutely
um but you've had bad experiences
working the street
a whole lot a whole lot what's the worst
thing that's happened
i've been raping these up a lot you know
one guy could be mad at one female and
come back and take that on the next one
you know what i'm saying
um what she didn't do he'll make me
he'll make the next person do
you know and that's what you know for
his life that i was living for as the
robbery
you know i could i could piss him off
today tomorrow he go check it out next
female
somebody else that he picks up or
whatever you know
yeah you know all but all johnson were
not like
you know i didn't have to do that with a
lot of them you know
a lot of them had a you know uh empathy
for me
you know and was willing to
listen you know and you try to comfort
me to a certain extent
you know i had i had to really go out i
never i never felt like i was
uh like a part of my family i was always
new i felt like an outsider because
if i didn't have anything to give them
you know my whole family was on truck so
if i didn't have nothing to give them
then they really didn't want to be
bothered with me you know it was only
around me because of what i had
you know to give or to share you know
something like that
um i had to go on the street to have fun
try to look
looking for love looking for love in the
wrong places and your relationship with
your pimp was
romantic or never never it was all about
money
and you give him all your money i did
to a certain i was very young and did
you ever
get anything out of it financially no
you take it all
you know until i learned you know
i was i was 12 you know 14 15 he would
take all my money
beat me up he would beat me up i would
run and hide from him i'll be in
people's houses
saying don't tell him i'm in here and
you know
he'd find me beat me up you know and put
me right back on the corner
did you start working as a prostitute
when when i was 12.
12. yes sir and how does a 12 year old
end up there well i told you the lady
that my dad was called was supposed to
be my dad's girlfriend
hit my sister and i told her and i hit
her you know he told me you can't
chastise my women for me you think
you've grown then you can go and see
i'll show you that you're not grown
you know there's a big responsibility
you know uh
he made me like uh he said you think
you're going to go ahead i never went
back home
you know so you ran away i did i did and
uh
i never went back i was uh
i was called i was arrested and um
instead of them
releasing me he told them to put me in a
girls home called garden gates
for all girls i went there
and i did get out of there um
i started all over again right back to
the same thing and you know
it was it was repeatedly things you know
the lifestyle you know it's i wanted to
get high
i said you know i mean i wanted to get
high and in order for me to get high i
know what it took for me to get high
and get my own so i didn't have to ask
anybody for
you know anything which i had to do
sometimes i had to you know
man up and do what i had to do to get it
you know not that i wanted to
it was all about the money do you
remember your very first time as a 12
year old
was that your first time having sex or
were you already my first time yeah i
was 12.
this guy that used to work for my dad um
it was one of his customers and uh he
used to always come to my house he used
to say if he was a little bit older
and he was just a little bit older and
you know i was real fast
you know um he told me that uh
when i got out the girl's home i
happened to run into him downtown
down here and uh on fifth and uh
what's that coming from broadway central
yeah and um there was a fat burger the
hard rock um
bar um i used to be conditioned with my
mom was too so you know
but i happened to see him i ran into him
and he was like when i got in this car
he was like i said can you give me a
ride to my desk
and i got in this car he said my place
of yours and we went to the snooty spots
and i've been i've been doing what i do
ever since then you know it's not
you know it went from bad to worse and
worse
you know me bumping my head learning my
experiences or whatever but
that's just how life is so a 12 year old
that gets
picked up or starts working as a
prostitute with a pimp
especially is that are you are you being
tricked or trafficked into doing that a
lot of times those tricks do trick to
girls
you know promises you know in your case
was that
was it your decision or somebody else
kind of got you into it i didn't have a
decision you know he just snatched me up
you know
he like gangstered me tell me what i'm
gonna do you know i'm saying you know
he's gonna what are you gonna do to me
so
could you get out if you wanted to i
didn't think i could
but i did i ended up getting a gun out
of one of the trix cars and i pulled it
on him and i let him know if he ever hit
me again
what i was gonna do to him you know
and uh they found him in his car
somebody had gave him a hot shot
and he you know he was dead
um that's how you got away yeah
and do you have children i have five and
did you raise them
yes three of them the other two were
drug babies
nothing that i'm proud of but um i am in
my kids life now
you know um how are your kids doing
great
they're doing great tremendous job
i am proud of them i can say that much
you know how old do you know
i will be thursday is my birthday i will
be 52. 52.
are you still working in the streets no
no no no no no no
that life is over with for me i'm a
married woman
um yeah i've been married for 18 years
yeah that life has been gone
over with what advice would you give to
a girl who's considering doing that for
a living
if she can get out get out you know
don't don't
um go for anything anybody tell you
because there's a lot it's a lot of ways
of tricking a person
you know saying one thing but then
there's something else you know
you have to be smart so i feel like i
tell my kids stay in school you don't
have to depend on nobody
you know it's all about education
education is power you know
it is like my baby she's 17.
you know she was a straight-a student
and you know she told me some things one
day she called me and told me that uh
she wanted to talk to me and she knew me
and i was like i'm coming i'm on my way
what's wrong
what's wrong she said i'm just tired of
doing drugs i said drugs
honestly i didn't know what to say to
her you know
because it was a shock to me you know it
was like hard you know
what do i say to my daughter i mean like
she told me she said mom i know about
you know the drugs i know what you do
and it's like i was like thrown back
like what do i say to my daughter you
know
and she children mimic their parents
they mimic what they see you know and
and that's the last thing i wanted my
daughter you know
she never seen me do it but she knew i
had a problem
she knew even as even as a kid you know
from
from you know one on up she knew i told
her i said well i do have an addiction
and it's a sickness
she used to tell me i got medicine
banana got medicine medicine in cabin no
not that kind of medicine that's not
what i want
but anyway um she told me she did drugs
she said she did just about everything
she said she tried it and they do it at
her school and
and that blew my hair back
that threw me for a big loop and i told
her i said the next time you get that
urge
or if you're angry you're stressed out
or you're you're bored
and you know you want just call me just
call me
you know don't go use you know don't do
that again because
when she i found out she was smoking
weed i told her that's not good because
see weed
anything alters your mind takes full
control basically
that's what i explained to her and you
cannot study in school smoking weed
that's when it started from the weeds
for her
so my daughter you know she told me she
would she'll give me a call you know
other than that you know i was shocked
when she told me she tried everything
i'm like you told me you hit the bike
yes mom i did the pipe i did the crystal
she told me she shot dope in her arms i
said well i say i want to know how
if you did how did it make you feel i
mean what was the side effects
how did you feel after you did she said
she was very sick
for a couple days you know i said good
please don't do that again
because that's the only effect that i
was i observed was people being on
uh dope using needles you know so
do you think do you think that teenagers
young kids growing up in the
it's different it's different you know
um because it wasn't like that
you know but but now it seems like it's
it's the norm almost
exactly to do drugs to to get into the
street life to do all this
yeah they wanted they want to fit in you
know that's all
you know they want to become someone you
know or be like someone
she always told me she wanted to be like
me but i want her to be better to me
better than me huh i'm sure there's
exceptions but it seems like there's a
lot of
well you can teach any child you can
tell them anything until they get a
certain age their minds may have to do
what they wanted to regardless
it's not all about what you taught them
but
when you unveil the right teaching to
them you don't have to worry about that
but you don't know what goes on when
you're not in your presence 24 8.
you know what do you think the most
misunderstood thing is
about women that work as prostitutes
that outsiders don't understand you
can't tell me you can't teach me
anything about the streets if you don't
know if you ain't living
you have to go out there and live their
life in order to know about it
like some people go to programs and
stuff like that you know it's also
certain type of addictions some people
do that just for a living
some people do that because that's what
they like that's that's their preference
you understand what i'm saying some
people do it because that's what that's
all they have to do you know
they don't have a choice it's all it's
all based on
choices
what was the best time of your life
know i don't know i can't i i can't say
well when i got married
that's yeah only my best time which was
recently
no 18 years ago oh 18 years ago you've
been married 18 years yes sir
well my husband is disabled now but um
we have a history
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in life
if i knew them what i know now there's
no way i would ever get involved in
drugs
you know and if i can
teach somebody else that or you know
i'll explain it to them or tell them
about it
don't do it if you don't do drugs don't
let nobody entice you to
trick you none of that because it's not
a good thing to do
it's not all right tanya well thank you
for sharing your story absolutely no
problem
it's nice nice hearing your life
you